in this capsule we will see the sentry box
nearest neighbor we are ready
to see our first to scream
learning is the deco algorithm
closest neighbors we'll see in
the context the classification so we're going
talk about a york classic at most
close neighbor it is probably
accept the simplest learning
to do the classification and we will
describes the idea here so
imagine that we have new entries
x and we want to try to predict
what is his class to associate with it
will do is we will find the
causes in very excited among the examples
of learning so the entries in
our training center which are the
closer to the new x entry
so we will have to define later
what do we mean by close
will have to define a notion of distance
between examples but for now
let's suppose we have young people
distance between the examples and that
can identify find the causes
nearest entries and country
exist closest to our
new entry x then when one in
France and we will vote each
each of the x telecom inputs plus
close neighbors for their class
associated yt and finally the class
we are going to return
classification that we will do for our
x100 input to be to return the
majority class the class that has
garnered the most votes among
xt entries that were closest
and if we have equalities all that
that can be done if they go back and
randomly a choice among the entries
classes with their the most votes
ok so the success of this algorithm is going
depend on two factors the first
what is the amount of data
training that we have
how big is our ensemble
drive so the number
example learning sets
learning that we have for among
which one will find our nearest
neighbor and more there will be but we
is going to be the gold performance that's it
something that is true for all
examples all the algorithms
learning etc goes among other things so
for the nearest neighbor's decorative grid
the other factor that will influence success
of the gatehouse it's going to be the quality of
the distance measure that we will use
to identify more pro body
3 and specifically we will see a
distance measurement that is going to be such that
if two entries are similar
then belong to the same class
yes we do not saw a distance so basis
basis of the policy there belong to
at the same class
we're going to want it to be high it exists
a lot of research work on
tried to learn good measures
from distance but in practice in the
nearby nearby Coptic grid in
this simplest version we are going
just use the distance or
Christian between intrigues
so if we at the input x1 we want to see
how far is it from the x2 input
we will just make the difference
element by element between elements
of the x1 vector and the x2 sector we are going
take the bus and sums offered the
sum then we'll do we'll calculate the
square root so and to get
useful distance and noticed again a
times dating I use bold
savoye correspond to vectors
tiny letters by engraving
typically correspond to vectors
and then it's in Italy that it's going to be
rather a scaler ok so that's
the deco algorithm more likely let's see
example imagine we want to do
of character recognition and
for simplicity we will do the
character knowledge with two
characters possible so be that our
vote to be one or a beauf he imagine
we are the training set
next where we have all our examples of the
class e
so here full of character image
manuscripts right now and we all have our
examples of the class or here so are there
handwritten characters that
match dice
so if we had a new entry
here that would match their bone x that we
had in the description previously
keep it as closest neighbor for
try to predict the class associated with
this entry there which would make think
that they would find the closest
neighbors so we made an example here or
what is equal to 3 so we find the
three closest neighbors in time
seems to drive so among the
training examples actually it's getting
find that the first neighbor is the one
the
the second is the third one
this is the one there is so these are the
neighbors because the distance between these
pictures there and this picture succeeded that
our new hold is the most
small so the three smallest among
all training examples among
the waters and the and the detention of
rockets the Euclidean distance so we have
makes the difference between what this one
and prick that one to the curry plus the
distance the difference between pixels there
and under pixels there and so on
we do the sum would include singer
so we are even closer neighbor
we look at what are the classes
associate the three find waters
and so the majority vote for number
of them it's going to be to say that it
belongs to the class at and in this case
if indeed we did have Qatar
or so we have a good prediction
we make no mistake for this new
entrance there but in our example where the
our new x entry is to be
a
and there it turns out that the three more
nearest neighbor nearest neighbor
it is well and truly had but both
following is to be waters and
no no and the sound makes the vote
majority in fact what we get
it is a prediction of a bone since
are two waters which is more than one
so when an example here where
unfortunately the copy strike
close neighbor makes a bad
prediction
now let's imagine we add two
years 200 example per class so at
departure we had only saint jean
we condemn adds 200 hours so for
each class means we have
found someone who generated 200 th
handwritten since 200 to writings to
the hand and then to identify what
which handwritten image of a character
correspond to which 1
correspond to waters
ok so get ready one person
or it could be a set of
people
obviously so we have human beings
who added two hundred examples
by class in our camp
drive
there we actually notice we are more
close neighbors they actually changed
there was who added here so if we
make the difference before actually
Forgiveness is the added xxx so we have
found a better first closer
neighbour
so whoever was the best neighbor
wind is made second and then the
third is the second high before
when we only had 100 examples
learning by class and thanks to that
we have now managed to predict the
good class to know
so that's an illustration of the fact
that if we add data
drive
so we add examples long
training center is expected to
that performance improves for
examples maybe a little more difficult
to be able to do a good
prediction
now we will make the link with the
definitions we saw earlier
we saw that mathematically
learning is watering that
corresponds to take our center
called training is
past be a function to who will be
our learning grid
so we will take the entrance of evaux
predict a function h that is going to be
will call model louis pautex so
it's the function that will make
predictions on new entries x
and in this case a calf match
so it's going to be a program a
algorithm that will itself produce a
program that will be the h function
our model if this model there so what
program there that he will do the
prediction with the decorating procedure more
close neighbors that we described then
we have seen an example previously so
h he came out of our mouth to
given our set of what they
want
the operation of this program this
h model
it's going to be to have the copies voted
close neighbors such as find in
our set for an entry
data and hdx is so the result
to run our program when we
provides as input our entry our
new entry x the function f in this
case which is the function that generated
our training data
if we take the example of the
character recognition does that
would be the human being where beings
humans who will have labeled our images
of character and generally the
heals neighboring copies on
can demonstrate that the more our whole
workouts and big meyer will be our
function h our model as being
proclamation of the dre function is so
the real behavior we're trying to
mobilize and intuition is that if we
increase the size of the room
Eco drive closer
neighbors can not be closer
so more similar to the input x so
the input that is given to our model
so is 6 then to give
more entries will be similar on
must then expect that our
prediction by making your majority
among neighboring copies are
better and better if we increase the
size of our training center
so that's for the algorithm of
classification with the nearby Copts
neighbors